tonight the avengers have a lot of
superheroes right now
but we have tina hello
[Music]
the marvel cinematic event arrives the
tunnel's assembled eternal free pt-13 be
the first to experience it tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good okay everyone that was good
we could do ten percent better that was
beautiful very very good because they're
really so good
how my friends from college are
ah
perfect timing welcome to the set of
chandar dastani icarus
i'm playing you
you like the costume we need to talk
tell the director i have some notes we
need to talk to you in private
oh karon he's worked with me for 50
years i trust him completely
actually when we first met he thought i
was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart
i've apologized so many times not quite
enough times very close though i'll let
you know oh i have to get ready for the
next scene come to my tent we'll talk
there you can you guys are gonna love
the next scene i come in on a wire
because you know i can't fly wait are we
getting back together we need to talk
the deviants are back
we don't know how many there are
you need to come with us
you